Please tell me that you go through this too:
So you're doing something random,
like primping, or eating,
or going back to high school
when you're a 20-something-year-old
reporter who's never been kissed,
when all of a sudden
the past comes to ASSAULT you,
with a horrible, embarassing,
cringe-worthy memory that makes you go,
"What was I thinking?"
I mean, it can be anything,
from some lame conversation you had..
TROLL IN THE DUNGEON!
I thought you would have known..
Eh?
Come on..
You read Harry Potter?
To that time you thought you were Catwoman
and things went horribly awry..
Ma'am, your daughter has been
banned from PetCo for attempting
to shoplift kittens.
Or some of your more, serious regrets.
Fuck.
I mean, it's weird.
Sometimes I get embarassed over things
I didn't even do.
Like, when I used to watch TV, I would
feel so bad when the characters messed up
that I could not watch them anymore.
And look, on one hand,
it is great that we can grow and learn
from our mistakes.
But then again, it sucks that we have memories
of those mistakes, and those memories
will come lurching to the present
with full force.
I mean, just thinking about who you were
6 months ago..
is disgusting.
You know nothing, John Snow!
Whenever the past assaults you,
just try to embrace it.
Like, "Oh yes, that memory was horrific.
But I'm sure no one other than me
is thinking about it right now.
And I can reassure myself that
there will be many more embarassing moments
in the future that I get to cringe over."
Cause there's gonna be a lot.
There's gonna be a lot of embarassing moments.
Still to come.
And relive, mentally, over and over.
So we have that to look forward to.
I'll see you next week.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara